unless you keep a prisoner in a glass
box and don't let him have any contact
with any individual whatsoever you are
going to get Contraband into prisons
there are so many different ways you
know I've had dead pigeon pigeons fall
at my feet Belly Up sewn up with drugs
my staff have searched babies with dirty
nappies um with drugs in
inside
first couple of years of my life up till
I was about 10 I lived in the states the
United States and then my mom and I came
back to England in about
1972 and I happened to be in London one
weekend and I saw a poster on the tube
for the prison service um and I thought
that that would suit me meeting people
quite structured I think on under the
poster it said something like you two
could make a difference and I thought
thought well maybe I can so I'll give it
a shot and that's what I did Holloway
was the the first prison that you worked
at yeah what was Holloway like then
Holloway was um well the old Holloway
was a very Victorian prison um it was
knocked down the old hallay in about the
1970s um and a new holay was was built
and this was built like a hospital
because they believed at that time that
women were mad and not bad I can only
say that it was um on par with an old
mental
institution what was your first day in
the job
like first day in the job um well you
can imagine the the cat calls and the
name calling and the jibing by by women
um prisoners that that you got as you
walk through the corridors I mean I I
rocked up to the gate and uh on on the
on the gate the senior officer in in the
gate at Holloway at that time she's
actually a really good friend of mine
now she said um what do you lot want and
that was kind of it was very much very
hierarchical um you know if you were a
young sprog you made the tea you didn't
go in the office I wasn't quite prepared
for sort of just anything that a
prisoner sort of has the ability to get
hold of whether that be Contraband or or
just an everyday object can be turned
into some type of weapon you know
prisoners could buy tins of tuna from
the canteen and of course like when you
open a tinner tuna you've got a lovely
Jagged Edge you can get toothbrushes
which are melted at one end and uh razor
blades um sunk into it they used to say
if you could work at Holloway you could
work anywhere and I firmly believe that
was
true who would you say the you know the
most notorious individuals are that
you've come into contact with prisoners
who are are in who are in the in the
Headlights who are high up in the media
like rose West Myra hindley you know the
media makes these people out to be
something that they're not they they
make them out to be notorious what was
she like rose West Rose West was we used
to call her Auntie Rose not to her face
but like have you have you unlocked
Auntie Rose because that's what she
looked like she looked like somebody's
Auntie she had thick you know milk
bottle
bottom glasses on um and um you know we
looked we looked after her that was what
our job was um but she was nothing
special and she's still nothing special
you came into contact with Myra hinley
as well didn't you I did I met I met
Myra briefly very briefly I did um a
transfer to uh cook and wood and she was
at cooking wood at that stage uh very
manipulative prisoner um she manipulated
a governor to take her to Regent Park
and have an ice cream Myra hinley only
did what Myra hinley wanted to do um I
was only a young officer only been in
the job at like 18 months and this
little sort of um mousy Brown woman with
this winging old cardigan came shuffling
along with sort of like the elbows out
and um this sort of I think it was brown
sort of or might have been a denim skirt
um she said What can I get you officers
and I said I'll have a cup of tea please
Two Sugars and she went around the three
of us that were there and um off she
shuffled again and um you know every
when people when you say the word Myra
hindley people think of the you know the
the infamous picture of her with bleach
blonde hair with the piercing eyes you
know staring staring Straight Ahead um
and she was nothing like that you
wouldn't have known her if you'd have
tripped over
for the next 11 years I stayed at
Holloway and then I moved to Wormwood
scrubs um and then my boss that was the
next Governor level up was a governor
four she went off to do she retired and
they asked me to step into her shoes um
and so within the space of probably four
years I'd gone from a senior officer
right the way up to a governor four so
my job was basically to keep the jail
safe and secure
and and trying to tackle the amount of
drugs that came into the jail do you
mind sort of getting into that then you
know actually you know Contraband coming
into prison well Contraband is um you
know it's it's it's the sort of bogey of
every single prison and by Contraband it
can be anything from you know hard drugs
heroin cocaine soft drugs spice cannabis
uh mobile phones mobile phone chargers
SIM cards alcohol alcool you know all
these sorts of things um are Contraband
and they contribute
to violence bullying assaults a very um
unstable prison um and the thing with
Contraband coming in there are so many
different ways you know I've had dead
pigeon pigeons fall at my feet Belly Up
sewn up with drugs I've had um my staff
have searched baby with dirty nappies um
with drugs in inside prisoners used to
have um food Parcels coming in because
any sort of chocolate bars that were
sent in we used to have to break them up
into little pieces and um whoever sent
this Kit Kat in had managed to reseal
the whole kit kat packet um had sort of
very delicately dug a bit of the kit cat
out poured a um a little wrap of heroin
in it down down one of the
I don't know what the biscuits um and
then poured chocolate over it and um you
know prisoners will think of any any
sort of means or to get drugs in we had
one one woman who was um a prolific um
drug addict and her mother at that time
FL um female prisoners were allowed to
have flowers in on a weekly basis and
her mother every week used to send her a
bouquet of flowers in and there were
drugs in the stalks of the flowers
little wraps of of heroin and um her
mother used to supply her daughter with
with these drugs and I you know you
could never understand it we used to say
to her Morin you haven't got your
flowers again cuz guess what your mother
had put drugs in them again but you know
unless you keep a prisoner in a glass
box and don't let him have any contact
with any individual whatsoever you are
going to get Contraband into prisons
and the problem nowadays is that you
know we have a lot of old Victorian
prisons that aren't fit for purpose and
technology has moved on in in this
climate so now they have drones bringing
drugs over so you know as I said when
when one door is shut and another one
will open and when you catch one dealer
you can bet your bottom dollar by
closeth a play that day there'll be
somebody else stepping into their
shoes
so what would like a
typical day look like for you when when
you when you ask me about a typical day
at at a at a jail there is no such thing
as a typical day yes you have a routine
that you trying to um adhere to but the
slightest thing can throw that out
nobody prepares you you know for self
harm for seeing somebody take a chunk
out of their their wrist and spitting
the flesh out on the floor nobody
prepares you for um some woman trying to
take their eyeball out or um sticking a
bro down into her veins in her leg and
leaving it to fester and go angriness at
that time when I joined the prison
service there was no after care for
staff there was no um sort of post
meeting about um were all the staff okay
you were just sort of thrown a you're
all right Frank uh yeah fine thank you
um and get got on with it onto your next
task things like that do have impact on
staff you know suicides have impacts on
staff you assaults have impacts on stuff
you know it's a very difficult job and
you see a lot of very difficult things
on a daily basis that most people don't
see in a
lifetime I had read that you know you
dealt with attempted escapes oh yes I I
did deal with um well I dealt with
escapes um there was a guy on uh it was
one lunchtime and a guy was feigning
illness and we thought he was feigning
Illness but the doctor insisted that he
go out to hospital we tried everything
we we uh I begged the doctor I not to
send him out he took no notice I I phon
the local police um they said they were
too busy but they'd send a car going
past um we found the hospital security
to warn them that we felt that this was
going to be an escape attempt and in the
end we had to send him out and um as
they came round into the A&E in the
ambulance um a car roared up hit the
back of the ambulance um the ambulance
staff obviously got out um to look what
was going on to be faced with um two men
with
guns um demanding that uh this prisoner
was uncuffed from one of the staff
um and
um he made good his Escape he was at
large for about six weeks before he was
eventually caught and um you know the
staff were in bits they um you know we
tried to sort of say to them you've done
absolutely the right thing because they
handed the Handcuff Keys over the three
staff that we'd sent with this guy um
One never worked again one um downgraded
from an officer to a uh an admin grade
and one unfortunately killed himself so
you know it has great
repercussions um and um something that I
will remember till I go to my
grave the difference between like men
and women's prisons what would you say
like is is one easier than the than
another or for me personally I enjoyed
working with men much more than females
women are quite emotional they're quite
they're usually the main carers so they
have children and all social prod um
problems that go with that um they're
much more spontaneous you know I've seen
dining rooms blow up over the size of
somebody's Christmas PUD that they
didn't think their peace was big enough
women can be quite nasty in groups
whereas men not so much they're more in
as individuals you know I think also I
think to a
degree male prisoners are more
respectful to female staff um and
whether that's just goes to sort of um
as it is on the outside you know I've
had prisoners hold open doors and I've
had prisoners step in between me and
another prisoner and him saying to the
other prisoner you know don't talk to
the governor like that and obviously you
get the odd one or two here and there
that aren't were there any moments where
you know you feared for your own safety
for your own life um I don't think I've
ever feared for my own safety um you
know I think once you decide that you're
scared or you're frightened um that is
time to give up the job we had a
prisoner who um was um very abusive to
female
staff um making sexual innuendos and um
I'd put him on basic regime which
basically means that his privileges are
taken away um in the hope that he would
realize that he can't go around um
making innuendos and sexual comments to
female style anyways he became very
irate over it um and um another prisoner
came up to me the day before and said
look gov you need to watch your back um
somebody's got it in for you and I knew
exactly who he meant it was this
prisoner that I just put on basic um but
the following night I was working late I
was trying to catch up on some paperwork
and there was an alarm bell went off on
Dewing on the fourth floor um and if
that happens then you know it's an
audible alarm and um you know you rush
to it as as quickly as you can um and
that's what I did and I got halfway up
the landing and I was just literally
stopped in my tracks covered in in this
uh this sort of liquidy stuff what a
prisoner does is he'll he'll will put
feces and urine in a bottle add some
water shake it up and leave it on a
radiator for a couple of days um and
then find some victim to throw it at um
potting is done to degrade humiliate um
and I was determined that that wasn't
going to be me got a couple of Staff
with me went up to this guy's um cell um
told him that he was going down the SE
told the staff to grab him and uh we
marched him off down the
seg so I hope it was worth it for
him and did you notice there was like a
hierarchy amongst the prisoners as well
yeah there's always a hierarchy amongst
prisoners you know um like I said
there's there's those that deal drugs um
who are quite top of the food chain and
then there's those who are in for
driving offenses um who come near the
bottom and then the real bottom ones are
anybody who who offends against
children um you know they're they're
they're seen as the lowest of the low in
in jail if we take say Lucy leby I can
guarantee you she will not be uh mixing
with the rest of the population you know
she she committed the cardinal sin she
murdered babies and a lot of women are
in prison have had to give up their
babies um because they've ended up in
prison or lost babies or or whatever um
and I expect Lucy letby will spend the
rest of her life looking over her
shoulder so who would you say the most
um evil person is that you've come into
contact with um the most evil prisoner
probably was col in Ireland I
accidentally bumped into this prisoner
and I turned around and I just kept
looking up and up and I mean he was he
was like six foot tall by six foot wide
he was huge guy um and he was the gay
killer um he used to um serial killer
again he used to uh um chat up men in
SoHo um and um kill them basically he
had these um unbelievable like pink
staring eyes I've never seen anybody
like it before and um he was probably
the one that like put the hairs on the
back of my neck sort of raised a bit um
I could see how he was an absolute
killer
do you believe that prisoners can be
rehabilitated I do believe um prisoners
can be rehabilitated but they've got to
want to be rehabilitated you know there
are plenty that fight the system and
think that the system they'll beat the
system and the system always wins I've
spoke to lots and lots of prisoners you
know if I had a pound for every prisoner
that said to me that's it Miss I'm never
coming back you know I would be a
billionaire um and a lot of that is to
do with the um support that prisoners
get you know bearing in mind 80% of
prisoners can barely reading right many
have problems with homes many have
problem social problems with with
addictions drugs alcohol when you give
somebody a three-month sentence bearing
in mind they'll only do six weeks there
is literally nothing you can do with
them in a jail in that time you know
that that person will probably lose
their uh lose their job lose their home
possibly lose their family you know but
they'll have had six weeks to learn how
to be a proper criminal you know I get a
lot of questions from people sort of
saying how do you how do you how can you
talk to prisoners you know you should
lock the door and throw away the key but
at some stage you've got to unlock that
door and let that person out into
society and if you've if you've treated
them like an animal then you unlock that
door and let them out onto Society
they're going to behave like an animal
that is that is fact you know I'm not
bullsh
here I left after 27 years I'd um I left
in 2013 I got an mve in 20 uh
12 um so I was at the Pinnacle of my
career really um worwood scrubs was in a
great place it was seen as um a trend
Setter um our security um system were in
place our drug um our drugs sort of um
drug rate was very low in comparison to
other London jails I we you know my wife
and I have a daughter at that time she
was always you know first in The
Breakfast Club and last out at the Tea
Time club and
um I barely saw her for 5 minutes and um
I wanted to spend some time with her
you know I've never been slow in coming
forward and speaking out and I could see
myself getting into a bit of bother um
by
constantly
um speaking out about the cuts and the
state of the prison and things like that
and when you start cutting back then
something has to give and whether that
be regimes or whether that be
reoffending programs or security system
systems or whatever I'd work my but butt
off so would my team um to make wormwood
scrubs a decent safe and secure jail and
it was just falling
around in front of me and I thought well
maybe it just needs a fresh pair of eyes
and uh so I put in to take uh redundancy
and I put my redundancy into my pension
and I drew my pension and I haven't
looked back do you miss the job at all I
did when I first when I first left work
I missed it dreadfully I I couldn't I
couldn't find my place in society I I
felt like well I felt lost if I'm honest
I felt absolutely like what was what was
the point of my being now I you know i'
I'd had this regimented job for 27 years
you know even now I have my lunch at
12:00 and I and I count people on the
top of a bus you know I still am so sort
of um in the zone of of regiments and
and that from the prison service that it
it's stayed with me for for for probably
will forever you know it's not an easy
job I'm not going to sit here and say it
is because it's not um but it is a
worthwhile job and it doesn't get the
recognition that it deserves there's
nothing more satisfying than you know
seeing somebody walk out of a jail um
and them not coming back and them
turning their life around that makes it
[Music]
worthwhile A car pulled up next to me
the window wound down I got chucked a
package into my car which was gay big
and then I got chucked 400 in rolled up
notes to which point I'm sat in a car
then thinking you know what have I just
done